you got it
all right so jenna i'm coming to you
first because we can kind of talk about
this scene because it's in the trailer
the most the sequence of course where
tara gets a ghost base call and it like
it kind of breaks my heart because your
performance is almost too good in that
in that whole sequence what is the key
to delivering work like that when it's
primarily a solo scene where it's just
you and a phone for the most part
um it's kind of difficult especially
because in this um
this scene specifically they kind of
added the
there's a landline
and then there's also the cell phone
with the social media apps and the
imessage and that whole thing so it was
kind of like it was
like playing out two scenes because you
you two different scenes um which was
kind of complicated and tricky
especially when prop phones are
you press the wrong button and it takes
you to videos of soldiers being welcomed
home from war by these german shepherds
and just really like really sweet cute
videos when you're trying to be serious
and give like this frightened
performance um so there's a lot of
technicalities and weird things like
that but i would say the trick is just
kind of um
i don't know it's really easy when you
have mr jackson on the phone doing the
actual voice and not really breaking
character in between takes to kind of
keep you humbled in in the moment so i
would say
get yourself a real ghost face
that sounds like a very good tip that i
wish more people could take take you up
on there
um before i move over i feel like i'll
be kicking myself if i don't say this
the fallout is phenomenal i'm like the
biggest scream fan in the world it's
very hard to divert my attention from
that but i want to make sure people know
about that movie
all right sonia moving over to you
first major role in a film did you get
any i guess feature filmmaking advice
before hitting the screen set that
really came in handy for you
oh i feel like it you know it happened
very quickly from you know when i
arrived there and then we started
shooting but um
yeah i was i was so i was so nervous i
just i wanted to do the film justice and
i wanted to also have such a great time
and um i think the biggest you know
lesson i learned was just being on set
with such talented people that's like
the best way to learn is just to be in
it and experiencing so like you know
having scenes with
you know um
such incredible actors has taught me um
i feel like a lot and
and that's what i kind of take away from
it
um
and i also just love them all so that
helps
with that in mind is there anything you
saw another actor do on this set that
you kind of are putting in your back
pocket and are hoping to use on a future
film
um
actually i was looking at
people's like moment before you know
what they do before like a scene and
and everyone's was
very different like i know
mason was just like always like goofing
around between takes i'm like very
serious before and i'm like trying to
get in um so i kind of like seeing what
people are doing and who's like focusing
and like what their tricks are and like
stealing people's little tricks and tips
here and there yeah well now i'll ask
you what's mikey's thing
mikey i feel like you're like very like
you're very focused like you're in your
zone and like you you're like very
peaceful before and
you're just like
in this bubble and nothing can burst it
you're very focused and professional
yeah oh yeah
you're a real pro
all right mikey so
i feel like this is another scene that i
could kind of lean on here because it's
also in the trailer and it's one of my
favorite moments in the entire movie
it's with you and jasmine having the
conversation in the basement but just
the the tone and the pacing of that
conversation is just like so spot on and
pitch perfect so can you tell me a
little bit about workshopping that with
jasmine and kind of what it was like
working with her as a scene partner on
that
um that scene was probably one of the
most
fun scenes that i i did jasmine and i
are really good friends in real life and
she was like my rock during filming so
we got really close and i think just
because of that had great chemistry and
were able to really play around with
that scene um
yeah she's great like we both you know
uh
every time we did the scene it was
completely different
um
and so it was just really fun like we
didn't want it to end when they were
like we have it we're like
maybe let's do it one or two more times
just for fun um
yeah she's she's a great scene partner
even as a viewer i was like this could
go on for another 20 minutes or so why
not let's just stay here
so in general one of my absolute
favorite things about horror movies is
when scares bleed into real life and
make me think twice about doing
something like answering a phone call
from an unknown caller so is there
anything that happens in this particular
movie or the entire franchise for that
matter that's really stuck with you in
that respect that's made you think twice
about something you do in everyday life
just people
people are scary
i don't i don't think it helps that
ghost face isn't this immortal
soul or figure or somebody who
lasts forever i think it's
part of what makes this movie so
exciting and thrilling is that it could
be absolutely anybody
whether it's someone you've known your
entire life or somebody that you've
known for just a few months so i think
knowing that it's a real color it's a
real possibility and also i mean he
wears a halloween costume like it's so
mocking and
disrespectful
it's just awful yeah people are scary
i feel like the one scene that like my
favorite kill scene from
the like first film is um
is when tatum gets killed by the garage
door opening i feel like from that scene
i don't want to step foot in in a garage
anymore
yeah very understandable
how about for you mikey
yeah maybe like what you're talking
about don't go into a basement alone
or
uh
i don't know
um
the most familiar of the bunch is i'll
be right back because like you say that
casually
and if i ever say it obviously my mind
goes directly to scream and i'm like
well what's going to happen next now
yeah
i'm still here though uh
for all of you i've heard that there was
a variety of rap gifts given out on this
set so can you each tell us one that you
got that was a lot of fun and unique
from some of the other projects you
worked on
jenna i still didn't give you a rap gift
because you left i stopped to give it to
you all right
sonia made these really great
cozy sweatshirts that say like woodsboro
really sick oh like the high school yeah
woodsboro high class of 2020. yeah yeah
i like that
um mikey
was taking
she had a great eye and she was taking
all of these like really cute film
photos and i just got it because i just
um
it's basically this little
photo book with
ghost faces mask on front it's a black
book but it's just kind of a memory of
our time in wilmington and um from the
beginning of the shoot to the end of
shoot off seat um you know offset on set
and it was just like a really sweet um
memento i think in them something that
you could always reference and look back
on
i love hearing that i have to let you
guys go a million more questions i'm
obsessed with this franchise and you
just gave me a great new installment so
thank you and congratulations to you all
you